All right, let's recap what we've
learned so far about strings.
We started out by talking about
what a string is composed of,
and we saw how to define
a string using a string literal.
Use letter var the way you would with
any other constant or variable, and
then type your string,
literal in between quotations.
We also learned that Swift strings
are coded with uni code scalers.
For this reason, we're able to
incorporate an uni code character in to
a Swift string including emojis.
Let’s make two strings similar
to those above, but this time,
use the monkey emoji and
the mobile phone emoji.
Remember, to access the emoji
keyboard in playgrounds,
you can press Ctrl+Cmd+spacebar.
We also learned that the strings
in Swift are encoded in a struct.
And the characters of a string can be
accessed through the characters property
belonging to the string struct.
For example, let's say we wanted to
count how many g's are in this string.
We could loop though all the characters
in this string using the character's
property like so and increment
a count each time we encounter a g.
And then if we type count
into playground, and
look over in the sidebar,
we can see that our count is five.
String interpolation is another
incredibly convenient feature of Swift
strings.
Here's an example.
Let's say we have to convert from an
integer representing number of pennies
to a string representing dollars and
cents.
We can use string interpolation along
with operators to get our solution.
We can calculate the number of
dollars by dividing by 100, and
we can calculate the number of
cents by taking the modular of 100.
Then, through string interpolation,
we can take this variable,
dollarInt, along with this expression,
and insert them into a string.
And you can see that string
here in the sidebar.
We looked at some common string
manipulations starting with string
concatenation.
For example, we can combine our monkey
string and our thief string to make
a very short story about
a monkey with sticky fingers.
We also learned that the swift
string struct is also
bridged to the NS string
class in objective C.
This opens a host of useful methods
including contained string,
string by replacing the current string,
and lots more.
Let's look at those
methods one more time.
Here, we're calling the method
containsString on the variable
monkeyString, and
we're passing in key as a parameter.
By doing this, we're asking if the
monkeyString contains the string key.
And over here on the sidebar,
we can see that the method returns true.
Here's another one.
Let's say our WiFi
password is meet me in St.
Louis but we need to switch it up a bit.
Let's replace all the e's with
3's using the NSString method,
stringByReplacingOccurrencesOfString.
And what you're looking at here is
the variable name followed by the dot
operator
stringByReplacingOccurrencesOfString.
And then the parameters we're passing in
are the string we want to replace and
the replacement string.
And over here in the sidebar,
we can see the result.